Fox News
melting down over the Trump indictment
you know we deal with a lot of serious
things on this show and Trump's
indictment is serious because it has to
do with no one being above the law but I
would be lying if I didn't admit
that it was a delightful pleasure to see
live on our stream yesterday Fox News
melting down check out this compilation
from Media Matters cat Abu this is just
it's really a delight I don't know how
else to say it Democrats are branding
Trump as a criminal it's legally
pathetic it's clickbait it is an
unbelievable abuse of Justice pure
Balderdash my heart is broken I had some
tears in my eyes we found the guy folks
we found the big strong guy with tears
in his eyes it's this guy Lou gellermino
a criminal defense attorney is broken I
had some tears in my eyes looking a
little emotional I feel the same way if
there's a mug shot of Donald Trump if
will be in dorm rooms and on t-shirts he
is an OG even if convicted that's not
going to stop him Donald Trump could run
in park on saying I'm going to Pardon
myself and go after uh the Deep State
there you go Jonathan Turley man that
totally really has hit his reputation is
just in the toilet at this point uh the
Deep State it's not open for a debate
that we live in a police state it's like
Stalin's purges we're Crossing the
Rubicon here this is a political Rubicon
that has been crossed they have crossed
the Rubicon basically it's one party
hunting another it almost feels like
they're pushing the population to react
it is they wore on conservatism and Maga
that's Mark Levin by the way screaming
at the top of his lungs there it's it's
really wild stuff react it is
they want you to strike out people
better be careful and that's all I'll
say about that yeah now in terms of all
of this stuff of the people aren't going
to accept this and blah blah blah and
it's be people better be careful
if they are insisting that the
indictment of trump is going to set the
country Ablaze and people are going to
rip it apart in Civil War and all of
this stuff the only obvious follow-up
question to that is who are the
individuals that are going to do that
and how do you know that they are going
to do it because what they are saying is
Maga is going to do all those things
you'd better be careful because of Maga
getting violent you'd better be careful
because they the Maga people will rip
the country apart now the upside of this
is
so far we're closing in on 24 hours into
this thing
it doesn't actually seem like the Maga
people care enough to even go out in
protest that's the amazing thing and I
hope there is no violence but for all of
these clowns saying this is going to be
a really bad thing it's going to
Uprising you're saying the trumpists
will be violent because the progressives
who like seeing Justice why would they
go in protest we're just going to follow
the story
incredible stuff that is going on and
you really do love to see it one of our
sponsors is zipx nicotine toothpicks
don't you think it's time you stopped
putting smoke and vape oils in your
lungs zippix toothpicks are a convenient
way to curb the nicotine Cravings zippix
toothpicks are super discreet you can
use them anytime anywhere smoking and
vaping aren't allowed including flights
sporting events in restaurants they're
available in six different flavors with
options of two and three milligrams of
nicotine if you're not a nicotine user
zipix also offers caffeine and b12
infused toothpicks zipx has already
helped tens of thousands of customers
ditch the cigarettes ditch the Vapes
they might be able to help you too if
you're a smoker or a vapor give zipx
toothpicks a try your lungs will thank
you go to
zipxtoothpix.com today save 10 percent
with the code pacman10 at checkout just
remember you must be 21 or older to
order the link is down below